le avec des fleurs tu as dit que quand
on aura vu ce film on pourra plus jamais
regarder les fleurs après non plus
jamais en tout cas pas en forme de
couronne funéraire ce wet est le cas et
ce qui a fait que je me suis retirée
sous les fleurs aux questions et que
j'ai plus fait ce film de cinéma je me
suis dit voilà le clic du cinéma ne me
verrais pas ils ne méritent papier film
ouais je me prive de bois dur dur je la
tête tu te décision du point de vue du
slogan quand même qui a bien marché lui
dans cette rue florival et j'aurais dû
faire que je dois changer ta vie parce
que je vais avoir une star et une petite
fille divine
j'ai cherché une fille qui lui ressemble
et ruan l'angleterre il vise les
burkinabè à fait réussie que j'ai menées
en france et j'avais engagé pour jouer
son rôle avec encore plus le cobra qui
était garé beau et je les présente les
prix et 2 et gainsbourg va déjà pas
prendre cette nana là parce qu'il faut
te dire que la fille que je vais
contacter c'était par les abbés redsun
mouais
à l'époque les grands médias du monde ce
qui faisait vaches pour veiller à serge
de jouer avec une fille
et comme diaby birkin belle commande
gauche est l'époux beurre qui ne
pleurait sans arrêt depuis fait de
l'espagne ce mec mais sinon il était
censé y rayonne à loin ce que j'ai fait
afin de prier sur le tournage
ses larmes la mère jane doit élire des
enfants on peut pas rester comme ça ce
soir on dit tous les trois chez maxi
j'ai retenu une table chez maxis à
vendredi soir et je suis pas allé à et
le lundi 20 heures gratuit de tournage
tout allait bien cet effet parce que
c'est sage bas par an pour ses additions
un salon auquel va toujours les
corrections de ne rien rater de finale
andy tube abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus